one thing I've noticed in our office
lately is on a personal note everybody
is getting a Fitbit I mean I know
fitbit's have been around for a while
but now everybody's getting a Fitbit you
Corsi it's the bracelet that measures
the number of steps you walk in a day
and it's just like it's it's insane how
many people have you I mean our society
yeah well I'm aware of it I just
mentioned it because I've been thinking
about getting one to start tracking my
steps now you would get one your sheep
what the hell Eddie what do you have
against Fitbit don't know nothing eh you
know it's great if you hate results why
all the hostility
I just don't think numbers and graphs
are the best way to exercise the best
way to exercise is fear hi I'm Andy
Richter and I'm launching a new fitness
product to help you meet your goals
roll it belly introducing the
revolutionary new fitness program that
will whip you into shape in no time
diet no gimmicks just a scary guy who
follows you around with a bat that that
uses your very real fight-or-flight
instinct to burn calories that the lover
off you don't keep walking Oh somebody
help me he is helping you to lose weight
you don't need any fancy bracelets or
athletic equipment there's no safe word
no off switch that that keeps working
until you get the results you deserve
Hey taking a break huh bud Baghdad Andy
Richter is not responsible for injury
death that may result from you becoming
drop-dead sexy when you use this product
but I'll show actual injury or death
congratulations Andy you are you really
sure this is safe of course
in fact my client Erin is here with us
tonight say iron
thanks Andy my experience with fat bet
has been great I've already lost 24
pounds and I should hit my goal weight
in just about oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fat bad run mother
and you see that that guide trip on the
stairs on the way up
oh you can't beat it
[Laughter]
he's alright he's fine
you